As you all know Ramadan is coming to us
soon. Ramadan is a month of forgiveness,
Ibadah worship, and a month in which a
person grows closer to his Lord. And it
was narrated by the companions that some
of them they would supplicate to Allah 6
months beforehand so that they would
reach the month of Ramadan by saying
Allahumma balighna Ramadan. Oh Allah,
allow us to reach the month of Ramadan.
And as you all know Ramadan is a month
of good deeds, charity, seeking prayer,
visiting the sick. All of these things
are from the actions of Iman and better
ones Islam. So in sha Allah let us
prepare for this blessed month and let
us not forget the message of appeal. We
need a new place. The community and the
Dawah is growing. And after Allah
Subhana wa Ta'ala permission we are in
need of your efforts and your donations.
So let us not forget the true
investment, the investment of the
afterlife. And as you all know the
narration
man ban Allah lahu baitan fil Jannah.
Whosoever builds a house for Allah for
his worship a mosque that Allah will
build for him a house in paradise. Who's
to say this can't be our last Ramadan.
So let us work hard collectively in
trying to establish a masjid and we ask
Allah Subhana wa Ta'ala our good deeds
and allow us to reach the month of
Ramadan. Barak Allahu feekum. Inna
alhamdulillah nahmaduhu
Man yahdihi Allahu fala mudillalah wa
man yudlil fala hadiyalah wa ashhadu an
la ilaha illallah
wahdahu la sharikalah wa ashhadu anna
Muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluhu
sallallahu alaihi wa ala alihi wa
sahbihi wa sallam tasliman kathira.
By the grace of Allah Azza wa Jal
we meet here at Masjid as-Sunnah
an-Nabawiyyah
in
Germantown, Philadelphia
with our brothers and the community
here.
And we thank them
we thank Allah Azza wa Jal and we thank
them
for this invitation.
And we ask Allah Azza wa Jal to grant us
beneficial knowledge
and righteous deeds and to accept it
from us all and to make us from those
who are sincere.
As the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "La yashkur Allah man lan
yashkur an-nas." Jazakallahu Khairan.
An individual has not thanked Allah if
they have not thanked the people.
So, we thank the people
and we ask Allah Azza wa Jal to accept
it from them.
Likewise, we remind ourselves and our
brothers and sisters
of the importance of having these types
of reminders
that benefit the believers in this life
and the next.
Allah Azza wa Jal said in Surat Al-A'raf
speaking about the believers
and when they enter into paradise
they say, "Alhamdulillah Alladhi Hadana
Lihada
Wa Ma Kunna Linahtadi Lawla An Hadana
Allah."
They say, "All praise be to Allah who
guided us to this.
We would have not been guided if Allah
did not guide us."
So, we thank Allah Azza wa Jal for
guiding us to faith and we know
what the disbelievers
are doing these days
and unfortunately, you have even Muslims
who are participating with the
disbelievers
in their celebrations of shirk
and the likes.
So, it is only the grace of Allah Azza
wa Jal that has brought us together
to benefit ourselves in this life and
the next.
Sheikh Abdurrahman al-Sa'di
mentioned about that verse in Surat
al-A'raf.
He said, "Allah Azza wa Jal
has blessed us
and Allah has given life to our hearts.
So, we have believed
and we've done actions which allow us to
enter into the paradise of Allah Azza wa
Jal.
So, this is a blessing from Allah that
Allah Azza wa Jal opens up your heart
and expands your chest
for faith
and makes you want to be from amongst
the believer in the companies in the
company of the believers. Well, like we
said, we have disbelievers.
We know what they're doing and
unfortunately, you have Muslims
that are doing it with them.
So, it is the grace of Allah Azza wa Jal
that we are here today trying to benefit
one another and our religion
and the likes.
My dear brothers and sisters,
the topic of or the theme of the
conference as it relates to
the signs of the day of judgment.
The signs of the day of judgment.
The minor the major and
the minor signs.
And this is in fact another blessing
that we should be grateful for that
Allah Azza wa Jal
before the reckoning
Allah has decreed that there are signs,
major and minor
so that the believers can take heed
and the believers can notice.
Allah Azza wa Jal said
in Surat al-Anbiya
Allah gave informed us of the
disbelievers.
Allah said, "The time of reckoning has
come close.
And they are heedless heedlessly turning
away."
Our Lord
speaking about the disbelievers, their
time of everyone's actually everyone's
time of reckoning is close.
And then Allah speaks about the
disbelievers, and they are heedlessly
turning away.
Sheikh Abdur Rahman
said about that verse,
"That this is amazement
with the condition of the people.
They do not benefit from any reminder
nor any warning, even though the time of
reckoning is close.
They do not benefit from any reminder
nor any warning."
So, my dear brothers and sisters, it's
very important that the believers take
heed to the signs that Allah has created
has created and placed before the day of
judgement because that is the mercy from
Allah has created.
Indeed,
this affair of the signs of the day of
judgement
are from the foundations of our
religion.
Knowing the signs of the day of
judgement is from the foundations of our
religion.
We all remember
and many of us even have memorized
the Hadith of Jibril Alayhis Salat
Wasalam
where he approached the Prophet
Alayhis Salat Wasalam
and asked the Prophet several questions.
He asked the Prophet Alayhis Salat
Wasalam about Islam.
He asked the Prophet Muhammad Salat
Wasalam about Iman.
He asked the prophet about Ihsan.
And then he asked the prophet Muhammad
about the day of judgement.
The prophet
said,
The prophet said the one who's being
asked has no more knowledge than the
questioner.
Then Jibril
said, "Inform me about its signs."
And the prophet
Muhammad went on to mention some of the
signs.
Then Jibril walked away.
The prophet
asked Omar,
"Do you know who was the questioner is?"
Omar
said, "Allah
and Allah and his messenger know best."
The prophet said, "That Jibril has come
to
teach you
your religion. That is Jibril. He came
to teach you your religion."
So Jibril
asked the prophet
about foundations of the religion.
And from that was his questioning along
with Islam,
along with Iman, along with Ihsan. From
that, he asked about the signs of the
day of judgement.
He asked about the signs of the day of
judgement. So that's an indication to us
that this is from the foundations of our
religion.
So the brothers and sisters taking it
upon themselves and the families
coming far and wide to learn this topic,
they are learning the foundations of
their religion.
It's from from what we want to mention,
it's from the mercy of Allah. We will
tell you.
That Allah will say it. We said it
before, we'll say it again.
It's from the mercy that Allah
has decreed that there are signs.
Allah says in Surat Isra, "Wama kunna
Allah says in Surat al-Isra, we will not
punish
until we send a messenger.
We will not punish until we send a
messenger.
Imam al-Tabari rahimahullah ta'ala from
the greatest scholars of tafsir and the
early scholars of tafsir, he said,
meaning we will not destroy the people
until we warn them by way of the
messengers.
And we establish the proofs upon them
with
evidence, so they no longer have any
excuse.
So they no longer have any excuse.
So Allah Azza wa Jal through his
infinite mercy
and want for good for the people, Allah
has sent warnings, signs, and
indications
so that Allah would not punish them
without them being warned.
Without them being warned.
Likewise, in Surat al-Nisa,
Allah says rusulan mubashshirin wa
munzirin li alla yakuna li al-nasi ala
Allahi hujjatun ba'da al-rusul.
Oh, hujjatun ba'da al-rusul. Allah Azza
wa Jal says in Surat al-Nisa,
messengers,
uh with giving glad tidings and warning,
so that the people do not have an excuse
with their Lord. So the people no longer
has have an excuse with their Lord.
Sheikh Abdur Rahman al-Sa'di
rahmatullahi alayhi said,
fa lam yabqa li al-khalqi ala Allahi
hujjatun li irsalihi al-rusul.
Sheikh Abdul Rahman is Saudi
so the people no longer have an excuse.
The people no longer have an excuse
because Allah has sent prophet after
prophet.
He said because the prophets and the
messengers they explained the affair of
the religion.
They explain what's pleasing to Allah.
They explain what's displeasing to
Allah.
They explain the path of Jannah. They
explain the path of hell.
explain the path of hell. He also says
further on
He said and from the wisdom of Allah
is that Allah sent messengers
and Allah sent down books.
This is from the wisdom of Allah. This
is from the bounties of Allah and this
is from the generosity of Allah.
So all of this my dear brothers as
relates to learning this topic
of the signs of the last day it is from
the bounties and the generosity of Allah
and we should understand that.
Likewise it's reported in Sahih
al-Bukhari
on the authority of Al-Mughirah bin
Shu'bah
that the prophet
said
that Allah
mean the end of the Hadith.
Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah said,
that the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said, "No one loves an
excuse
more than Allah."
"No one loves an excuse
And because of that, Allah sent givers,
yani messengers, to give glad tidings
and to warn.
Then,
in explanation of that that Hadith, that
no one loves an excuse more than Allah,
al-Imam ibn Mulaqqin,
in his explanation of Sahih Bukhari, he
said,
He said, "What's meant that no one loves
an excuse more than Allah in this
Hadith,
what's meant is that Allah loves that
the people repent and that people return
to him."
Allah loves that the people repent and
they return to him.
So, when Allah azza wa jal
has decreed
and created the signs before the Day of
Judgment, whether those signs are minor
or whether those signs are major, it's
so that the people can see the sign,
acknowledge it, realize it, and repent
and return to their Lord. So, indeed,
this is from the tremendous blessing of
Allah azza wa jal upon the ummah.
Likewise,
the signs
are reminders for the people to prepare
to prepare for that which comes after.
The signs, major and minor,
are signs
and warnings for the people to prepare
for what comes after.
You have in Sahih Muslim,
on the authority of Abu Hurairah,
that the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, "Badiru
the prophet
said race to do
good deeds or race to do good deeds
and then he said six
the scholars say meaning before six
so the prophet said race to do good
deeds before six
he said
before the sun rises from the west
I would
before the smoke
I would the Dajjal before the Antichrist
the Dajjal
I would Dabba or before the beast
then the prophet said and before death
or a general calamity
so the prophet
in this Hadith
said race to do good deeds before six
so that remind and then the prophet
mentioned the rising of the sun from the
west
he mentioned the smoke
he mentioned the Dajjal which is the
topic of my lecture
and he mentioned the beast and he
mentioned death
so the prophet
is reminding the believers of the
importance of doing good deeds before
before the final day
it's Imam Muslim
in his Sahih
he gave a chapter to these types of
narration from the prophet
Imam Muslim said in his Sahih Bab
al-Hathi
ala al-Mubadarah bil-A'mal qabla tazahur
al-Fitan he said the chapter
of racing to do deeds before the
appearance of tribulations
so notice Imam Muslim
is giving you his understanding
we should race to do good deeds before
the appearance of fitna.
Imam Nawawi
who explained Sahih Muslim, he said,
"The meaning of this Hadith
is that an individual races to do good
deeds before he no longer has time to do
it.
Before he no longer has time to do it."
And he says, "Before the fitna,
and when the fitna approaches, it will
continue and become more intense."
So, this is an encouragement for people
to do good deeds before the major trials
and tribulations.
It was also mentioned by al-Haafidh ibn
Hajar
in his explanation of Fath al-Bari.
He said,
Imam ibn Hajar,
he said, "The wisdom
in signs, major or minor,
coming first,
yani before the day of judgment, the
wisdom
in signs preceding the day of judgment
is to wake up the people who are
heedless.
Is to wake up the individuals who are
heedless
and to encourage them to repent and to
prepare."
And in the wisdom, there is wisdom.
There is tremendous wisdom
in the fact that these signs precede the
day of judgment
and that is to wake up the people who
are heedless and negligent
and to encourage them to repent and to
prepare.
So, my dear brothers and sisters,
these types of gatherings are important.
These types of gatherings are vital.
These types of gatherings are gatherings
for us to learn our religion.
And the Sahaba
were very keen
on learning this from the prophet
was selling.
It's reported in sahih Muslim
on the authority of
ibn
radi allahu anhu.
He said can in nasu yes
Rasul sallallahu alaihi wasallam and the
hair
what come to
and the show
ma
and you can me.
Who they say in the man radi allahu anhu
one of the companions that narrated the
hadith about the Dajjal he said in a
different narration that the people used
to ask the prophet was selling about
good
and I used I used to ask the prophet
about evil out of fear that it would
reach me.
So who they say in the man is informing
you that he was very keen on knowing
about the evil.
Knowing about the warnings
so that he could be cautious when they
approached.
So these are
some of the benefits
of learning about
the last hour
and learning about the signs major and
minor that precede and come prior to the
last hour.
And there are many. There are many
benefits. For example, for an individual
like it it was mentioned by Imam
Alusi in his tafsir
any of the fact that Allah
did not
just surprise us with the day of
judgement?
Imam al-Alusi mentioned in his tafsir,
he said,
it's
strengthens obedience
and it strengthens an individual's
ability to abstain from sin.
And it it strengthens
and promotes obedience
and it also makes the warning
and fear of sin greater. Why?
Because
because the individual sees the signs,
like we said, the individual sees the
signs.
Now the individual realizes your time is
close.
So the individual it promotes and it uh
strengthens the individual's desire to
turn to Allah Azza wa Jal and abstaining
from sin. Because he realizes his time
is close.
And he realizes the final hour is near.
Likewise, the Salaf mentioned
also from the benefits of knowing the
last hour, it strengthens your faith.
They strengthen your faith
because
when the Prophet Muhammad was Salam
spoke about
the signs of the hour
the major and the minor
and when those signs become a reality,
the believers realize that the Prophet
was Salam has what? He has spoken the
truth.
So it strengthens their belief.
It strengthens their belief.
So this is another benefit that the
scholars they've mentioned about
understanding, realizing
and witnessing the signs of the last
hour.
As it relates to the affair of the
Dajjal,
we should understand that this affair is
we should understand how the Salaf
viewed this affair.
And how they gave it great importance to
the extent
to the extent that they mentioned this
affair
in their books of Aqeedah.
And we're going to mention some examples
of that.
For example, you have Imam Ahmad
in his Usul as-Sunnah.
Imam Ahmad Rahimahullah Ta'ala who died
241.
And notice the dates
cuz it's consistent in the books of the
Salaf.
Imam Ahmad in his Usul as-Sunnah.
And Imam Ahmad died 241 Hijri.
He said,
"Wal Imanu
annal Masih ad-Dajjal
kharijun maktoobun bayna aynayhi
kafirun."
He said, "And faith." This is Imam Ahmad
in his Usul as-Sunnah.
He said, "And faith
that the Masih ad-Dajjal will appear.
And it is written between his eyes
kafir.
The word kafir is written between his
eyes." To the end of the statement of
Imam Ahmad.
He also said in another
letter or treatise that he wrote to one
of his students, Musaddad bin Musarhad.
As is mentioned in at-Tabaqat
al-Hanabila
that Imam Ahmad wrote a letter to one of
his students
speaking about Aqeedah.
And he said, "Wad-Dajjal kharijun fi
hadhihi fi hadhihil ummah la mahala."
He said, "The Dajjal
will appear in this ummah. It cannot be
avoided.
It cannot be avoided.
That was Imam Ahmad and he died what
year?
241.
You also have it mentioned by Ibn Abi
As, Ibn Abi Asim and he died 287.
Imam Ibn Abi Asim and he died 287.
He mentioned babun
fi qissat al-dajjal.
The chapter
the story of the dajjal.
And then he went on to mention the
narrations
about the dajjal.
That's Ibn Abi Asim and he died 287.
You also have it mentioned by Abdullah
Ibn Ahmad
the son of Imam Ahmad and he died 290.
In his book As-Sunnah, yani Imam Ahmad
has Usul al-Sunnah
and his son has As-Sunnah.
And he the son of Imam Ahmad also
authored a book.
And he died 290. He has a book bab ma
warada fi dhikr al-dajjal wa sifatihi.
The chapter
what has been mentioned about the dajjal
and his description.
What has been mentioned about the dajjal
You also have Kitab al-Tawhid by Imam
Ibn Khuzaymah.
And Imam Ibn Khuzaymah died 311.
Imam Ibn Khuzaymah
and my brothers and sisters, these are
books of the salaf.
These are books of sunnah and aqidah and
tawhid of the salaf.
Imam Ibn Khuzaymah
who died 311
he has his book
Kitab al-Tawhid and in it bab
dhikr al-aini lillahi jalla wa ala
wa awrada
He He has a chapter called
the mention of the eyes of Allah.
And then in that chapter, he mentions
narrations about the Dajjal.
He mentions narrations about the Dajjal.
And it will come.
Why does Imam Ibn Khuzaymah in the
chapter of the eye of Allah or the eyes
of Allah, why does he mention the
narrations related to the Dajjal? It's
going to come.
Then you have Imam al-Khallal.
He has a book called as-Sunnah. And Imam
al-Khallal died 311.
The same year as who?
Ibn Khuzaymah.
Two mountains of knowledge in the same
year.
Imam Ibn Khuzaymah died 200 311.
And Imam al-Khallal died 311.
And in his book as-Sunnah,
he mentions the chapter of the Dajjal.
He mentions the the the chapter of the
Dajjal.
Then you have Sharh as-Sunnah
by al-Barbahari.
Sharh as-Sunnah by Imam al-Barbahari, is
it translated?
Yes. Sharh as-Sunnah by Imam
al-Barbahari, it's translated.
And Imam al-Barbahari died 3 329.
He died 329. He said,
"Wal iman bil Masih ad-Dajjal."
In one of his uh in a portion of Sharh
as-Sunnah, he said, "And faith in the
Masih ad-Dajjal."
In faith in the Antichrist.
That was al-Barbahari who died 329.
Then you have Kitab ash-Shari'ah.
You have Kitab ash-Shari'ah by Abu Bakr
al-Ajurri.
And he died 360.
Imam al-Ajurri
he died 360. Ash-Shari'ah is it
translated?
A portion of it.
A portion of it is translated.
One of the greatest books of the Salaf.
So much so Sheikh Rabi' Hafizullah
Ta'ala he did a full explanation of
ash-Shari'ah.
And his explanation is
uh it's printed. It's published. It's
called adh-Dhari'ah.
It's called adh-Dhari'ah. It's
published.
Imam al-Ajurri mentioned in ash-Shari'ah
in many chapters
not just one or two in many chapters he
mentions the narrations related to the
the Dajjal.
He has the chapter
of the fear of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam upon his
Ummah
and his warning about the nations that
came before. He mentioned the Dajjal.
He has the chapter belief and faith in
the punishment of the grave. He mentions
about the Dajjal. He has the chapter of
belief in the Dajjal
and the fact the Dajjal would appear in
this Ummah.
And he has the chapter
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
seeking refuge
seeking refuge from the Dajjal. So Imam
al-Ajurri al-Ajurri
in his book ash-Shari'ah Imam al-Ajurri
mentioned the Dajjal in many places in
that book.
Likewise, you have Usul as-Sunnah li Ibn
Abi Zamanayn
who died 399.
He has a chapter Bab al-Iman bi khuruj
ad-Dajjal faith
he has a chapter called faith in the
appearance of the Dajjal.
And he said,
"And Ahlus Sunnah believe
in the appearance of the Dajjal. May
Allah protect us and you from his
fitna."
May Allah protect us and you from his
fitna. And in another place,
in another place he said, "And Ahlus
Sunnah believe
in the appearance of the Dajjal and Isa
will kill him."
And Isa ibn Maryam will kill him.
Then you have Usul al-Sunnah wa I'tiqad
Afwan
Sharh Usul I'tiqad Ahlus Sunnah by Imam
al-Lalakai
who died 418.
Imam al-Lalakai died 418
and in that book he mentions the Dajjal.
Then you have an I'tiqad by Imam
al-Bayhaqi
who died 458.
He has the chapter on the Dajjal.
Then you have al-Hujjah
fi Bayan al-Muhajjah li Qawam al-Sunnah
al-Asbahani who died 535.
He has the chapter on the Dajjal.
Then you have an Iqtisad fi al-I'tiqad
by Abdul Ghani al-Maqdisi who died 300.
He has the chapter of the Dajjal.
And then you have Lum'at al-I'tiqad by
Ibn Qudamah al-Maqdisi who died 620. He
has the chapter of the signs of the last
day and the appearance of the Dajjal.
My dear brothers and sisters, what we
wanted to show you
the year 200, 300, 400, 500, 600, all of
these books of Aqidah
and Sunnah
and Tawhid were authored by the Salaf
and these were only a few examples.
And all of these books of Aqeedah had
the chapter of the Dajjal.
So indeed
it was something very important to the
extent that the Salaf of this Ummah felt
the need to mention it in their books of
Aqeedah.
As it relates to
the affair of the Dajjal, we want to
mention a few things
in today's lecture and tomorrow's
lecture.
In today's lecture
bi idhnillahi ta'ala, and we know it's
at the end of the day so some of the
brothers and sisters are tired.
But we ask you to be patient with us bi
idhnillahi ta'ala.
In today's lecture, what some of the
things we're going to mention
why was he named the Dajjal?
Why was he named the Dajjal and the
Masih ad-Dajjal?
Another thing
the appearance of the Dajjal is the
greatest tribulation that has ever take
place in
since the creation of the world.
The appearance of the Dajjal
or of one the appearance of the Dajjal
is the greatest calamity that has ever
taken place since the creation of the
world.
Likewise
the description of the Dajjal.
Likewise some of his actions
and what he does.
Those are some of the things we hope to
cover in tonight's lecture
and then tomorrow bi idhnillahi ta'ala
we will continue.
As it relates to
why was he given that name?
Or the meaning of that name. Ad-Dajjal,
the word Dajjal is taken from the word
ad-dajal.
And the word ad-dajal means to cover
and to hide.
The word ad-dajalu
means to cover
and to hide.
It was mentioned by Imam ibn Athir
in his book Jami' al-Usul.
He said, "Al-Masih ad-Dajjal, Masih
means to wipe." One of the words or the
meanings of al-Masih is from the word
masaha, to wipe.
He said, "The reason why the Dajjal was
called Masih
is because one of his eyes is covered
or it's blind.
It's covered or it's blind.
So, that's why he was given the name
al-Masih ad-Dajjal.
That's why he was given that name.
It was also, yarhamukallah, mentioned by
Ibn Athir in another book. He has a book
called An-Nihaya
fi gharib al-hadith. Imam ibn ibn Athir
has a book where he explains words from
hadith.
In that book, he said, "Dajjal, the word
Dajjal,
it means someone who lies.
Someone who is a liar."
So, the word Dajjal, just like it means
to cover
or to hide, it also means to lie or to
to deceive.
It also means to lie
and to deceive.
In that regard, he brought a narration.
And it was a narration
that Abu Bakr, radiyallahu ta'ala anhu,
had approached the Prophet, sallallahu
alayhi wasallam,
and asked to marry Fatima.
That he approached the Prophet,
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and asked to
marry who?
Fatimah.
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
responded and said, "Inni wa'adtuha li
Ali."
"Wa lastu bi dajjal."
The prophet responded to Abu Bakr and
said, "I've already promised Ali that he
could marry her and that I am not a
dajjal, meaning I'm not a
I'm not a liar."
And that's another fa'ida that we get
from that.
And this is off topic but on topic.
Abu Bakr
and we know that Abu Bakr was very old,
right?
He was old. And Fatimah was
young.
So, Abu Bakr asked the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam if the hadith
is authentic, I didn't do the research.
But if that hadith or that narration is
authentic, Abu Bakr asking the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam to marry
Fatimah, her being young
is an indication that it was something
common those days for senior men to
marry
younger girls.
It was common. It was something known
that older men would marry young much
girls that were much younger.
And that's why you have the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam marrying who?
Aisha radiyallahu ta'ala anha. And
that's why in reality, and this is off
topic but it's something important for
us to know.
If you look at everything that the
kuffar
during the time of the messenger
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam, and this is
important.
Because this is one of the shubuhat.
This is one of the doubts that the
people who oppose Islam come with.
Right? When they claim that the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam was a what?
A pedophile.
If you look at
the shubuhat or the doubts that were
brought by the kuffar during the time of
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and said he was uh he was a magician or
he made up these stories himself or he
learned from the people of the past or
the likes.
None of the Kuffar of Quraysh said he
was what?
A pedophile. Why? Because it was
something common during that time.
It was something common during that
time. Even the historians
during that time and those who came
later, they never they never accused him
of being a pedophile. Why? Because it
was something known that time.
Amongst the Arabs and the non-Arabs.
So, my dear brothers and sisters, if
there was any they tried all types of
accusations, but they did not make those
accusations.
Because if you wanted to say it for him,
you would have to say it for many
people.
And this is a clear example of Abu Bakr
coming to the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and asking for Fatima. Al
Muhim, what's important is that the
Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
to Abu Bakr, "I've already promised
Ali that he could marry her and I am not
a Dajjal, meaning I'm not a liar."
Meaning I'm not a liar.
So, the scholars mentioned
So, the re So,
the reason why the Dajjal is given that
name is because he's a liar.
And he's a deceiver.
He's a liar and he's a deceiver just as
what was mentioned.
Now,
it was also mentioned
by Imam an-Nawawi
in his explanation of Sahih Muslim,
he said kullu kadhdhab fahuwa Dajjal. He
said every liar is called a Dajjal.
This title is given to everyone who is
known to be a liar.
And he also said,
"But it is also said that he is Masih
ad-Dajjal because his eyes are covered.
Yani, he's blind.
He's blind in one eye
or the likes.
It was also mentioned by Imam Ibn Hajar
in Fath al-Bari.
He said, "He's called the Masih
ad-Dajjal because he covers the truth
with falsehood.
He covers truth
with falsehood."
And it's also mentioned
that because he goes throughout the
earth with deception and lies.
He goes throughout the earth with
deception and lies.
The next part.
The appearance of the Dajjal is the
greatest fitna that has ever took place
upon the earth.
This is mentioned
in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Imran bin Husain
radi allahu ta'ala anhu
that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said,
"Ma bayna khalqi Adam
ila qiyam as-sa'ah khalqun akbaru min
ad-Dajjal.
There is not
Yani, the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said,
"From the time of the creation of Adam
until the final hour, there is no
creation greater than the Dajjal."
And in another narration it says,
"There's no affair
greater than the Dajjal." Meaning, the
fitna.
There's no affair greater than the
Dajjal. Meaning, the fitna.
It's also reported in Bukhari and Muslim
on the authority of Abdullah ibn Umar
radi allahu ta'ala anhuma
that Abdullah ibn Umar said,
And we'll translate if the narration is
long, we'll we'll translate it directly
to save time.
Abdullah ibn Umar said,
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
stood up one day
and he praised Allah
with that which Allah deserves.
And then the prophet mentioned the
Dajjal.
And the prophet said,
Then the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, I am warning you from
him.
There is never a prophet except that he
warned his people of this individual.
There is there was never a prophet
except he warned his people from this
individual.
Then the prophet said, "Nooh warned his
people."
Yani, from the beginning of the
prophets.
From the beginning of the prophets.
Then the prophet said,
"I will inform you something
that no prophet told his people.
Know
that he is one-eyed
and Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala is not
one-eyed. He's blind in one eye and
Allah is not blind in one eye. The point
of this hadith or the shadd
from this hadith is what the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said,
"There was never a messenger except that
he warned his people from the Dajjal."
Likewise,
is reported by Abu Dawud
and ibn Majah
and others
on the authority of Abu Umamah al-Bahili
that the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said,
"Ya ayyuha an-nas,
innahu lam takun fitnah
ala wajhil ard
mundhu dhara Allahu dhurriyata Adam
a'dhamu min fitnatid Dajjal."
The prophet was said oh mankind
There has never been a fitna
on the face of the earth
since the time Allah created Adam
greater than the fitna of the Dajjal
And indeed Allah has never sent a
prophet except that he warned his nation
of the Dajjal.
It's likewise reported in the Muslim
Ahmed.
On the authority of Jaber ibn Abdullah
that the prophet
said
The prophet
there was never
and there will never be
a greater calamity
than the calamity of the Dajjal. Notice
the prophet there was never
and there will never
be
until the day of judgement
a tribulation and trial greater than the
trial and tribulation of the Dajjal.
Then the prophet said
and there was never prophet there was
never a prophet except that he warned
his nation of the Dajjal.
Then the prophet said
and I'm going to inform you
of something
that no prophet said to his nation to
the end of the Hadith.
And at the end of the Hadith the prophet
said
The same thing the prophet said, "And I
swear that Allah is not blind, yani, the
Dajjal is one-eyed."
So, notice in that Hadith, the Prophet
said,
"There was never
and there will never be a tribulation or
trial greater than the trial of the
Dajjal." And that Hadith was was
reported in the Muslim Imam Ahmad and
declared authentic by Shaykh al-Albani,
rahimahullah ta'ala, in his Sahih.
Likewise, it's reported also reported in
the Musnad of Imam Ahmad
on the authority of Hudhayfah ibn
al-Yaman
that the Prophet
said,
"Ma suni'at
mundhu kanat ad-dunya
sagheeratan
wala kabeeratan illa tudhayyi'u li
fitnat ad-dajjal."
Hudhayfah ibn al-Yaman
said
that the Prophet
said, "No trial,
whether it's big or small,
in this world, since this world has been
created,
no trial, whether big or small,
can compare to the trial of the Dajjal.
And every calamity becomes small
when it's compared to the calamity of
the Dajjal.
Every trial becomes minute
when it's compared in comparison to the
trial of the Dajjal."
It was mentioned by Imam an-Nawawi
in his explanation of Sahih Muslim.
He said,
"Fitnat ad-dajjal, yani, fitnatan
shadeedatan
jiddan wamtihaanan ha'ilan." He said,
"It is a tremendous,
difficult, tribulation
and a extremely difficult test.
It's an extremely difficult calamity and
an extremely difficult test.
As it relates to his description
as it relates to his description.
And before we mention his description
we once again remind our brothers and
sisters
that it is from
the blessings of Allah
that Allah has described him.
So that the believers can acknowledge
and so that the believers can to be
aware
and so that the believers can be
cautious.
If Allah Azza wa Jalla did not describe
him
his description
and if Allah Azza wa Jalla did not
decree
that his prophet and ordered his prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
to describe him with intricate details
his physical description
his actions
where he will
uh
where he will be presented
and the likes then it would be a
calamity.
But from the tremendous blessing of
Allah Azza wa Jalla is that Allah Azza
wa Jalla described him.
Notice what the Sahabah in these
following narrations
Is that the battery?
I thought
Notice what the companions
Radiallahu Ta'ala Anhum said
how the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam
was intimate
in describing the Dajjal.
It's reported in Ibn Majah
and Abu Dawud
on the authority of Abu Umamah
al-Bahili, the same narration we said,
the long narration.
Where the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "Ya Ibadallah."
"Ya ayyuhannas, utbutu.
Fa'inni sa'asifuhu lakum sifatun
lam yasifha iyyahu qabli nabiyyun."
Then the Prophet went on to describe
him.
And this long hadith
of Abu Umamah al-Bahili,
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, "Oh slaves of Allah.
Oh mankind,
be firm.
Because I'm going to describe him unlike
any prophet has described him before."
So notice the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam
is
reminding his servants, be patient. Be
firm.
I'm going to describe him like no other
prophet has described him. So you will
be aware of him. If you see him,
if you hear about him,
you will be aware so that you can be
cautious. And then the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam went on to
mention that description and we're going
to mention it.
It's also reported in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Nawwas ibn Sam'an.
And this is also a long hadith, but
we're going to take
a portion.
When Nawwas ibn Sam'an ibn Sam'an radi
Allahu ta'ala anhu said,
"Dhakara Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam ad-Dajjal
dhaaka dhaata ghadatin fakhuffidha fihi
wa rufi'a hatta dhanannahu fi ta'ifatin
nakhli."
And Nawwas ibn Sam'an, another
companion, said, "One day
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
began to speak about the Dajjal and he
went up and down. You know, I mean he
was so detailed in his description. You
know, up and down
and he up and down.
You know, like when you say you the
individual looked up and down
and he didn't leave anything.
So, Nawwas bin Sam'an
who said the prophet mentioned the
Dajjal and he went up and down. You
know, I mean from the most minor to the
most detailed description
and he described him to the extent that
we thought that he was over there in the
the the big pond.
And in the Sahabah, the Prophet was so
descriptive that the Sahabah thought
that the that the Dajjal was close.
He was that close
because of how detailed the Prophet was
was in the description of the Dajjal.
It was mentioned by Imam al-Qurtubi
in his book at-Tadhkirah.
Imam al-Qurtubi
has a book on
the description of
uh
the punishment of the grave and the
description of
uh
the day of judgement and the likes. Is
it translated?
Yes, a portion of it is translated.
A portion of it is translated.
And that's the favor that Allah
has blessed this community
cuz we said a portion of Sharia is
translated, right?
And published where?
Zaytuna College. And at-Tadhkirah, a
portion of it is translated and
published where?
Hikmah, in this city.
This is the favor that Allah
has bestowed upon this community. That
is the favor of Allah
This is the bounties of Allah. He gives
it to him he wills. And in both those
books we mentioned were published in
this city. Jazakallahu khairan.
Imam al-Qurtubi said in his book
at-Tadhkirah,
he said,
Imam al-Qurtubi said,
pay attention to this statement by this
great
scholar from amongst the salaf.
He said, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam described Dajjal
with such detail, anyone with
understanding is not unclear about this
description.
If you have any type of understanding,
it is absolutely clear the description
of the Dajjal. May Allah Azzawajal
protect us all from him.
As it relates to his physical
description,
for example, his hair.
For example, his skin color.
For example, his hair
and his skin color.
And his appearance
is mentioned in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Ibn Umar.
Mentioned in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Ibn Umar
that one day the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam
said to them
that in his sleep that the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam saw a man
and he was fair complexion
with straight hair near straight hair
near the Kaaba. And by the way,
this first part is Isa ibn Maryam
alayhis salatu wassalam.
So, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam saw a man
with a fair complexion and straight
hair. Near the Kaaba.
And he was supporting himself on two
individuals.
And water was flowing from his hair.
Water was flowing from his head.
Or trickling from his head.
So the prophet
said
And in other narrations to the Malaika,
who is this individual? They said, this
is Isa ibn Maryam.
This is Isa, the son of Maryam.
Then the prophet said
Then the prophet said, then I saw a man
behind him.
He was very light or red.
And we'll explain that. He was very
light complexion or red.
And his hair was woolly or very very
curly.
And he was blind in one eye.
To the end of that Hadith.
The prophet said
Who is this?
They said
Al-Masih ad-Dajjal. That is the
Antichrist. That is Al-Masih ad-Dajjal.
So in that narration, the prophet
mentioned the complexion of the Dajjal
as being red.
In another narration, it says white.
We'll come to the explanation of the
scholars in that regard.
The prophet said his hair was very
woolly.
Or extremely curly.
And he was blind in one eye or in his
right eye.
It's reported in Bukhari and Muslim.
Also on the of one. It's reported in
Ahmad, the Muslim of Imam Ahmad.
On the authority of Ibn Abbas
that the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam described the Dajjal and he
says aqmaru hijanan.
Aqmaru hijanan, he is very
white.
He is very white.
So how do we reconcile and harmonize
between these narrations? The narration
that he's red
or the narration that he's white.
It was mentioned by Imam Ibn Athir
in his An-Nihaya, the same book that we
mentioned earlier
where he explains
uh
difficult, unfamiliar words and Hadith.
Ibn Athir said
hijanon aqmar means extremely white.
It means extremely white.
Then it's mentioned by Imam Ibn Hajar
in Fath al-Bari
that he reconciles between the two.
He says
that amongst the Arab
when an individual is extremely when the
when they say he's he's red, that means
he's very white to the extent that he
looks
that he looks pale and he looks red.
He looks red.
So these narrations are there's no
contradiction or discrepancy in these
narrations. Yani, he's so white, he's
red.
He's so white he's so pale skin that
he's red.
Likewise in terms of his physical
appearance
it's mentioned in the Musnad of Imam
Ahmad
and also the Sunan of Abi Dawud
about his height
and his size.
On the authority of Ubadah bin Samit
radiyallahu ta'ala anhu
on the authority of Ubadah ibn Samit
radi Allahu ta'ala anhu
that he said
that the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
"I will speak to you." And this is
another narration that shows us how the
Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
so keen
on explaining the Dajjal to the Sahabah.
The Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said, "Inni
qad haddathtukum an ad-dij- an ad-dajjal
hatta khashitu an la ta'qilu."
The Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said, "I've spoken to you so much about
the Dajjal,
I feel that you will possibly not
understand."
Yani,
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said so much he felt that
the amount of information that he gave
the Sahabah about the Dajjal, they would
begin to forget it.
Yani, the more and more that I talk,
the more you would the less you would
grasp.
So, the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that to the Sahabah.
And then the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said,
"Inna Masih ad-Dajjal rajulun qasir,
afhaj,
ja'dun, a'war,
matmus al-ain."
Then the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam gave a portion of the
description.
He said, "He is someone who is short.
He is pigeon-toed.
He has woolly hair.
He is one-eyed.
And he is sightless in one of his eyes."
So, the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said in this narration,
he is short or tall?
Short.
And he said he's pigeon-toed.
Pigeon-toed is the type of individual
when they walk, their feet are not
straight, but their feet are turned in.
Their feet are turned in. So, instead of
walking like that, they walk like this.
So, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam mentioned his height,
and he mentioned that he's pigeon-toed,
and he mentioned that he has very curly
hair,
and he mentioned that he's one-eyed or
he's blind in one eye.
Likewise,
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
in another narration in Bukhari and
Muslim,
on the authority of Evan Omar,
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
mentioned the Dajjal,
and he said, "Inna Allah la yakhta
alaykum.
You are aware of Allah.
Inna Allah laysa bi awar.
Wa ashara bi yadihi ila aynihi.
Wa inna Masih ad-Dajjal awar al-ayn
al-yumna.
Ka anna aynahu aynabatun tafiya."
In another narration, the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said to the
Sahabah, "You know about Allah. Yani,
Allah has described himself, and I have
described Allah."
Then the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "Allah is not one-eyed."
And the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam pointed at his eye.
"Allah is not one-eyed.
And the Dajjal is one-eyed.
His eye is His right eye is blind."
Then the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "His right eye is like a
protruding grape."
So, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam described the eye being
sightless,
and then he described it as being a
protruding grape.
Imam an-Nawawi, Hafiz an-Nawawi,
said in his explanation of Sahih Muslim.
He said,
"This means
that Allah Azza wa Jal is free from all
blemishes. Yani, pay attention to this.
Yani, from from the wisdom
of Allah creating the Dajjal and he has
these physical blemishes,
right?
He has these things that are considered
a blemish.
Imam an-Nawawi said, "Allah is free from
any types of defects."
And the Dajjal is created by Allah.
And he has several defects.
Notice what Imam an-Nawawi is saying.
Uh
the Dajjal is created by Allah.
And he has several defects.
He said, "So, you must know this.
That the Dajjal has blemishes
and defects.
So, you must know it.
And you must teach it to the people.
Like the brothers and sisters are doing
this weekend. You must know it. You must
learn it.
And you must teach it to the people.
So, that people are not deceived
when they see his miracles or his
actions and his tribulations or trials.
So, notice what Imam an-Nawawi
mentioned.
Yani, from the wisdom of Allah
creating the Dajjal
with these blemishes and these defects
is that you know that your Lord does not
have defects. The Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam said, "Inna Allaha
Jameelun yuhibb
al-Jamal. Allah is beautiful and Allah
loves
beauty.
The Prophet mentioned Allah is beautiful
and Allah loves beauty.
Right? But the Dajjal
this individual this individual is short
this individual is pigeon-toed this
individual is blind-sided
and the likes. All of these defects that
the Prophet
has described the Dajjal
is also mentioned by Imam al-Qurtubi
in the same book at-Tadhkirah.
And like we said, the abridged version
of it has been translated and published.
Jazakum Allahu Khairan.
Imam al-Qurtubi says
when the Prophet
said he's one-eyed, yani he's blind in
one of his eyes
Imam al-Qurtubi said
this is a reminder
and an indication
for anyone even if they have
less intellect
and less understanding. And this is a
great statement by Imam al-Qurtubi.
Yani when the Prophet said he's one-eyed
or he's blind
Imam al-Qurtubi said
this is a warning
and precaution
for the the intellect even if you have
less intellect and less understanding.
Right?
That this individual has blemishes in
his creation.
And in in his appearance. How Allah
created him, he has blemishes.
Then notice what Imam al-Qurtubi says.
Man kana naqisan fi dhatihi
ajizan an izalatihi naqsihi
kana ajaza an naf'ihi ghayrihi
Imam al-Qurtubi said wonderful
statement.
And the lesson that we take from this,
he said, "If an individual
has defects and blemishes
that he himself can't change
or alter,
then more so, how can he change or alter
anything else?"
How can he benefit anyone else or harm
anyone else?
Yani
And the reason why Imam al-Qurtubi said
that
is because as we're going to see,
the Dajjal is going to claim to be
Allah.
Yani while he goes throughout the earth,
he's going to claim to be Allah.
So, Imam al-Qurtubi said, "If he has
blemishes that he can't change himself,
you can't fix yourself, you want to fix
others?
You can't benefit yourself, how can you
benefit others?"
So, this is a clear indication
of the extent of his deception.
And we add to that statement of Imam
al-Qurtubi that
you don't have to have a lot of
intellect
to acknowledge
and realize that he's the Dajjal.
Because it doesn't take a lot of brain
to see his blemishes.
Right?
An individual, it takes intellect,
it takes high order thinking
to respond to someone's
uh
refutation or respond to someone's
argument. You have to be intellectual
and the likes.
Like Shaykh al-Islam ibn Taymiyyah
ta'ala, one of the most intellectual men
that have ever walked the earth.
Right?
But it doesn't take a lot of intellect
to
uh
because you can just see that he has
problems.
That's what Imam al-Qurtubi is saying.
You don't have to have high level of
intellect and understanding to realize
that he's the Dajjal. You can clearly
see it.
You can clearly see it especially with
the description, the intricate
description of our beloved messenger
sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
There's an affair.
And that is
you find some narrations that say he's
blind in the right eye.
You have other narrations that say he's
our in the left eye.
Imam Nawawi said all of these narrations
are authentic.
Because the statement or the word of the
amongst or the word in the Arabic
language of our
blind means it has a defect.
So we understand that the Dajjal
we understand and we conclude
and the scholars harmonize or reconciled
between these narrations that seem to
have discrepancy. Imam Nawawi said we
understand that he has blemishes in both
eyes.
He has blemishes in both eyes.
Another description of his eyes
as we find in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Hudhayfah al-Ghifari
that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said
the Dajjal one of his eyes is covered.
alayha zafaratun ghaliza
There is heavy thick skin
covering one of his eyes.
There is heavy thick skin covering one
of his eyes.
Another
example of his description.
And that is what is written on his head.
It's reported in Sahih Bukhari and Sahih
Muslim
on the authority of Anas ibn Malik radi
allahu ta'ala anhu
that the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
ad-Dajjal mamsoohul ain.
His eye is covered or blind.
Maktoobun baina ainaihi kafirun.
Thumma ta ja'aha.
Anas ibn Malik said that the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, "One of
his eyes is covered.
And it is written between his eyes
kafir.
Then the Prophet said the individual
letters, kaf fa ra.
Then the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said the individual letters.
And the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, "Every Muslim will be
able to read it whether they can read or
not.
Whether they can read or not."
Another part of his description, he's
barren. He cannot have children.
This is reported in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Abu Sa'id al-Khudri.
And that narration
is that there was an individual present
during the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that had a
physical description similar to the
Dajjal.
So some of the Sahaba thought he was the
Ibn Sayyad or Ibn Sayyad.
So Abu Sa'id al-Khudri narrated that
someone approached him.
And I can't recall was it Abu Sa'id
al-Khudri or someone else.
And asked him, "Are you the Dajjal?"
And he responded by saying,
"Did not the messenger say that he's
barren, he cannot have kids? I have left
my kids in Medina.
I have left my kids in Medina.
So, this is also from the description of
the Dajjal is that he is barren. He
cannot have offspring.
He cannot have offspring.
And what type of woman would want a man
anyway?
Now,
another description of the Dajjal
is that he has a large body. Even though
he's short,
he has a large body. It's mentioned that
his chest is wide or his body is just an
enormous size body.
That's reported in Sahih Bukhari
on the authority of Ibn Umar
radiyallahu ta'ala anhuma
that
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said, and he's mentioned in the same
narration that he was sleeping and he
had a dream.
And when the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam saw Isa, the same narration, he
saw Isa at the Kaaba.
And then the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said, "Then I saw a man who was
red complexion
and he was enormous. He had a large
body.
And his hair was curly or woolly. And he
was blind in one eye.
His eye was like a floating or
protruding grape."
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said, "Who is that?" And they said,
"This is the Dajjal." The point of that
hadith is where the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam said, "He had a huge
body."
It's also reported in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Fatima bint Qais
radiyallahu ta'ala radiyallahu ta'ala
anha
that she mentions the
the event of Tamim al-Dari radiyallahu
ta'ala anhu
where they meant where they met the
beast.
And the beast told them to go to the
monastery.
And they entered
and Tamim said,
And he mentioned the rest of the
narration. Tamim al-Dari
radiyallahu ta'ala anhu said, "After
they saw the beast
and the beast directed them to go to the
monastery
and they entered it,
Tamim said, "Then I saw the largest
creation that I've ever seen.
Then I saw the largest creation that
I've ever seen. And then Tamim al-Dari
radiyallahu ta'ala anhu went on to
mention
the story of the Dajjal.
Some of his actions.
So notice, my dear brothers and sisters,
the physical description. Notice the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam gave
us a clear, detailed physical
description.
So the believers, when they see him
or when the believers hear about him,
they abstain.
They're cautious.
Right? They're aware.
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
as the Sahaba said, "Khaffada wa rafa'."
Up and down. He did not leave anything
about this individual.
From his actions.
And this will be the last thing that we
speak about this evening.
We'll continue tomorrow bi idhnillahi
ta'ala.
From his actions.
It's mentioned in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Hudhayfah ibn
al-Yaman radiyallahu ta'ala anhu
that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said, "Ma'ahu jannatun wa nar.
Fa naruhu jannatun wa jannatuhu nar."
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said, "He has with him paradise
and the hellfire.
His fire
is actually paradise
and his paradise is actually the
hellfire.
He has with him
paradise and the hellfire.
And he seemingly to the people
and they see that this man can bring the
paradise and he can bring the hellfire.
And the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "His fire
is paradise and his paradise is the
hellfire and we will come to
to explain that."
In the other narration
in another narration Hudhayfah
Radiallahu Ta'ala Anhu said
"I am the most knowledgeable about the
Dajjal
yani from the Sahabah."
Hudhayfah ibn al-Yaman said, "I am the
most knowledgeable
about the affair of the Dajjal, yani
from amongst the Sahabah." Then he said
"Ma'ahu nahran yajriyan. He has rivers
flowing."
Yani this man can make rivers flow.
"Ahaduhuma ra'yal ain ma'un abyad
wal akharu ra'yal ain narun
tahajjaj.
Fa in ma adrakanna ahadun falyati nahra
alladhi yarahun aran.
Walyughmid
thumma then he mentioned to the end of
the narration
that Hudhayfah Radiallahu Ta'ala Anhu
said
"He has two flowing rivers.
Apparently one of the rivers is pure
water flowing
and the other river is fire.
And the other river is fire."
Then he said "If anyone sees these river
go to the river that you think is fire.
Notice.
This clear description and instructions.
If you see the river,
right? Your eyes
Your eyes, you will think that one river
is pure flowing water.
And the other river is a river flowing
with fire.
He said, "If you reach the river,
then go to the river that looks like a
fire,
close your eyes and drink from it. It
will be cold water."
Approach the river.
Approach the river that seems that it's
fire.
Close your eyes.
li yutahti ra'sahu
fayasrab minhu. Close your eyes.
Be firm.
Be confident. Close your eyes and drink
from it. It will be cold water.
This was
what Hudhayfah ibn Yaman radi Allahu
ta'ala anhu said he heard the messenger
say, salla Allahu alayhi wa sallam.
This is what Hudhayfah ibn Yaman said he
heard the messenger say, salla Allahu
alayhi wa sallam.
Another description
of what's with him.
As was reported in the Hadith of Nawwas
ibn Sam'an in Sahih Muslim.
And it's a long Hadith that we will read
from. We'll translate it directly.
And Nawwas And Nawwas ibn Sam'an radi
Allahu ta'ala anhu said
that the Prophet salla Allahu alayhi wa
sallam said
he would appear on the path between
Syria and Iraq.
So, now we know
where he's going to appear.
So, it's not that we only know his
physical description.
How he looks.
How tall is he,
his facial his face, his body, his walk,
right? But, we also know where he's
going to appear.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said,
"He will appear on the path between
Syria and Iraq.
And he will spread mischief everywhere."
Then the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, "Oh servant of Allah,
uthbutu, be firm.
Be firm what I've taught you what I've
told you."
Then the Sahabah said, the Sahabah began
to ask questions.
The Sahabah said, "Oh messenger of
Allah, how long will he stay on the
earth?"
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, "For 40 days.
One day like a year.
And one day like a month.
And one day like a week.
And the rest of the days like your
days."
So, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam described the time that he
would stay.
Then, further down,
the Sahabah said,
"How quickly would he walk upon the
earth? And if from place to place?
How quickly will he move about upon the
earth?"
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, "He will come
said,
like the the cloud which is driven by
the wind.
Very quickly.
Like the clouds that are pushed by the
wind."
Then the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said,
"He will approach a people.
And he will invite them to believe in
him.
He will say, first, I'm a prophet.
He will then say, I am your lord.
So, he will invite people to believe in
him.
And they will affirm There's some people
that believe in him.
There are some people that they will
affirm their belief in him.
When those group of people
affirm belief in him,
he will order the sky to rain.
And instantly it will rain.
Instantly it will rain.
And instantly crops begin
to sprout from the ground.
And
to the extent that animals come later in
the day
and their bellies are full because
they've eaten from the crops. So, it's
not just an illusion.
It's not just an illusion.
And you have the you have the He points
at the sky, it rains.
Immediately the crops come.
The animals go, the cows, the sheep,
they graze.
Later on in the day, they come back and
their bellies are full. So, it's not an
illusion.
Right?
Then the prophet said, then he would go
to another people.
And he would invite them.
But they reject him.
And he goes away from them.
And they are
afflicted with drought.
Can we understand the fitna?
And he goes to some people, they believe
in him.
He orders it to rain, it rains.
The crops come up, the animals feed. So,
those people are happy and comfortable.
Right?
Then he goes to another group of people.
And he says, believe in me. They they
reject him.
He walks away and there's pure drought,
no rain, no crops, nor anything.
Right?
He will then walk to a wasteland.
He will walk to a wasteland.
And he would say, bring forth your
treasures.
And all forms of treasures will come out
of the ground.
And they gather in front of him like the
swarming of beads. You know how beads go
to the honey?
And they all come from different parts.
All different types of treasures would
gather in front of him.
Then he will call a young person.
And he will strike him with his sword
into two pieces.
Right? A piece on the left,
a piece a piece on the right.
Then he would say, "Come to me."
And that individual
that he killed
comes back to life.
And he walks toward him.
And at that time Allah
would send Isa ibn Maryam alayhis salatu
was salam.
That time
Isa ibn Maryam alayhis salatu was salam
would come until the end of that Hadith.
So, what was mentioned in that Hadith?
Yani, he would be able to point at the
sky and does what?
It rains.
And the crops.
And
Right? And the drought.
Right? Killing someone and bringing them
back to life.
Killing someone and bringing them back
to life.
It's also can still see the extent of
this calamity.
And these are his actions. It's also
reported
in Ibn Majah,
the long Hadith of Abu Umamah al-Bahili.
And we'll translate some of it.
The Prophet sal Allahu alayhi was sallam
said, "He will start by saying, 'I am a
prophet.'"
And then he will say, "I am your Lord."
And then the Prophet sal Allahu alayhi
was sallam said, "You will not see your
Lord until you die."
The Prophet sal Allahu alayhi was sallam
is reminding us
because the Dajjal will say, "I'm a
prophet." Actually,
I forgot a sentence. All right, I
skipped a sentence.
The prophet
would say, "He will begin in
for your and a prophet."
The prophet said, "He will begin his
mission
by saying, 'I'm a prophet.'"
Then the prophet said, "Well, no prophet
after me." The prophet said, "But
there's no prophet after me."
Then he would say, "I am your lord."
Then the prophet said, "You will not see
your lord until you die."
So notice, my dear brothers and sisters,
the prophet
is teaching them.
He begins his mission.
He's saying he's a prophet.
But remember, there's no prophet after
me.
Then
the next phase of his mission
and he develops from saying, "I'm a
prophet."
to saying, "I am your lord."
Then the prophet said, "But remember,
you will not see your lord until you
die."
So at each interval, remember, he's
lying to you.
No matter what you see,
he's lying to you because there's no
prophet after me.
And him saying he's your lord, he's
lying to you because you will not see
your lord until
until you die. Notice how specific the
prophet Muhammad was
in clarifying the affair of the Dajjal.
Then the prophet said,
"He is one-eyed.
And your lord is not one-eyed.
Is written between his eyes, kaf fa ra."
Then the prophet said, "Every believer
will read it.
If he's literate or illiterate."
Then the prophet said, "Part of his
fitna
is that he will have paradise and hell.
But his hell will be paradise, and his
paradise is hell."
Then the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam said,
"Whoever is tested with his fire,
let him seek help from Allah
and recite the first verses of Surat
Al-Kahf."
The prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
said, "Whoever is tested with him,
let him seek refuge in Allah
and let him recite the first verses of
Surat Al- Al-Kahf."
Then the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam said, "It will be coolness and
safety from him from the fire.
It will be coolness and safety from him
from the fire."
Then the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam said,
"A part of his fitna, and we will close
with this last one because we don't want
the brothers and sisters to fall
asleep."
The prophet It's been a long day now.
The prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
said, "Part of his fitna will be that he
will say to a Bedouin, 'What do you
think?'"
Yani, and I'll say it.
The prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam is
explaining that he will say to a
Bedouin,
"What do you think?"
And this Bedouin, his parents have
passed away.
This individual, his parents have passed
away.
The Dajjal would approach this man and
say to him,
"What do you think if I resurrect your
father and mother?
Will you believe in me?
If I bring to life your father and
mother?"
This is what you call these days
uh emotional
What do they call it? Manipulation.
Emotional manipulation.
Yani, he's tapping into your emotions.
Everyone loves their father and mother.
So, your parents have died, right? Yes.
What do you think if I bring them back
to life?
Will you believe in me?
Right? So, he manipulates this
individual. He says, "What if I
resurrect your father and your mother?
Will you bear witness that I am your
Lord?"
The Bedouin will say yes.
Then two devils will appear to him in
the form of his father and his mother.
And they will say, "Oh my son, follow
this man.
Indeed, he is your Lord."
See the extent of that fitna?
Another part of his fitna,
that he will overpower a single soul and
kill him. You know, he will go to an
individual and kill him.
Then he will cut him into two.
One part on the left, one part on the
right.
And then he will say to everyone who's
following, everyone who's witnessing,
"See my servant? I will resurrect him.
I will bring him back to life.
I will bring him back to life." Then he
brings him back to life and he says,
"Who is your Lord?
Who is your Lord?"
That individual, one of the individuals
that he kills and brings back to life,
one of those individuals will say,
"Allah is my Lord and you are the enemy
of Allah. You are the Dajjal. By Allah,
I have never had more
faith than today."
We ask Allah Azza wa Jal to make us of
those individuals who have firm faith in
Allah Azza wa Jal, in Islam, in the
Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam. We ask Allah Azza wa Jal to
protect us from the deception of the
Dajjal and his calamities and his
tribulations and his trials. We ask
Allah Azza wa Jal to guide our hearts
and the hearts of our family members and
our children. Allah knows best. Wa
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam wa barak ala
Nabiyina Muhammad wa ala alihi wa
sahbihi wa sallam tasliman kathira.